hey there reject nation I'm looking for
a Twinkie
oh and I'm neurotic and I've just
learned confidence arguably you should
be wearing this side of the curly hair
you know I switch no there's no time
well that means I have to be like I'm
stoned then if we're going by hair you
know who you really look to me I just I
just see Heath Ledger right so awesome
let's watch this Zombieland double tap
red band trailer yo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you'll be the first to die I like your
enthusiasm you might die yeah they defer
your sacrifice
[Music]
[Music]
this year suggested here
well this looks okay it's like a really
long time
felt like if this this one in particular
feels like an advertisement as if this
is like some one of those omae's
reunions ball and breaking bad and yeah
it's kind of like gonna do an obstacle
course with us this doesn't feel like a
real movie to me for some reason
no right I don't know the advertisers
been just kind of confusing to me
because of how late they decided to
promote this I know this comes out in
like two weeks usually those kind of
things cause concern because it doesn't
look like a bad movie it doesn't look
like it's made poorly at all like in
fact it looks bigger than the last one
those action sequences that they have
the monster trucks looks really exciting
I like the expansion of the world by
like literally like weird carnival kind
of people are yeah I mean even that
reminds me of the first movie just
because of the theme park yeah yeah but
that was like at the very end this but
this one has a much bigger inclusion of
more people it's maybe a population now
maybe the survivors is some kind of safe
haven hiding something and all those
cool slow-mo shots they keep promoting
and Emma Stone
I heard she took a pay cut so she could
be in this movie really oh yeah I mean
you know she's the only one between the
four of them who won an Oscar I and as
in the past few years to Sochi so it's
pretty cool that would someone with her
clout decided to return for this one
because this is one of the movies that
really helped she handled several movies
that people reference as to what really
catapulted her career
and this is one of those movies to me
it's exciting everyone looks like
they're bringing their a-game here I
don't know if I'm just worried because
of the the math of the timing of the
marketing the only that's really holding
me back a little bit there's nothing in
the marketing that seemed especially
fresh or like this sequel is altogether
an event like it feels like a sequel
yeah you know but it doesn't necessarily
feel like this is the the grand
follow-up to Zombieland somehow which is
weird because it's like everyone came
back it's like Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick are on the script for this
Bill Murray don't worry somehow back hey
like yeah they seem like they really
went all out and I'm just surprised by
like the lack of fanfare around this
entire thing well I couldn't tell what
that Bill Murray moment was yeah I mean
either because he's gay and everybody
I'll rope Roker right yeah from Good
Morning America Today Show one of those
someone with Al Roker he's getting
interviewed there it sounded like it was
a thing mocking and what made him appear
in the first Zombieland movie either
that other Garfield joke why would there
be like television media doing news
promotions in this zombie apocalypse
landscape you know what I mean so it
seemed like some weird maybe that's the
opening of the movie or maybe it's some
kind of weird flashback sequence that
has something to do with that how
breaker I don't know cuz like easy very
clearly died in the last movies so
unless there's some weird retroactive
continuity they're about to pull on it
or unless Bill Murray is just immortal
in this universe or maybe it's not even
in the actual movie and they just threw
it in here I could also sees I could
believe that very much it was a deleted
scene from the first movie yeah yeah yes
I'm a lot of Achor the trailer and
Murray I'm surprised you haven't gone
like you know Twinkie jokes and stuff
especially because of how they're like
really reminding us of the past alive
yeah well I'm surprised they also
haven't showcased very much the new
characters I mean the the blonde girl
gets some you know time to shine in this
trailer but like dude it was everything
is okay yeah yeah yeah her blonde hair
threw me off but uh rosario Dawson I
thought they
I have made something more out of her
presents especially because he's at
least important enough to have gotten a
poster those additions to the cast don't
seem to be very touched in this trailer
well Luke Wilson his characters called
Albuquerque oh what's that's crazy
Thomas Middleditch as we saw in the last
trailer is called flags see that's the
thing is I completely forgot about that
also III think they're not together in
this movie I'm guy I love that trope
yeah like such and like a 90s sequel
truth to do we're back but we're back
there care the actors are back but
they're broken up so you got a reroute
for them to get back together yeah yeah
they're gonna make us work I think the
one who they have the most capability to
really let grow is Abigail Breslin
actually yeah because she went from
teenager to she's a she's an adult at
now right man she's like 48 yeah yes
really
Hollywood clones man I'm sure it'll be a
fine movie I want it to be good there's
nothing here that has led it to be that
has led me to think this is gonna be a
bad movie but there's nothing here that
has led me to think this is gonna be
good yeah yeah and it's I don't know
yeah I'm having that same issue with
both of these ads where there's
something off and I can't quite put a
finger on it yet because the general I'm
is excited by the you know prospect of a
new zombie land at least a bit like I
like the first one yeah remember when we
saw it and remembered you know people it
was really fun yeah to have it finally
come back after all this back and forth
over the years and after this whole like
Amazon Show deal and it doesn't feel
like yeah as much of an event is yeah we
shall see people all right guys well are
you excited for zombie land double tap
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects you can click that
notification bell I'd like to give a
patron of the day shout out to a man
named Matthew beer now you see Matt beer
he's got
neurotic miss and the hair of jesse
eisenberg but he's also got the swagger
of a woody harrelson and the breasts of
an Emma Stone the feminism of Abigail
Breslin but the cool laid-back Ness of
Luke Wilson he's got that Tufts ass like
rosario dawson and that irresistible
quirk like Bill Murray Matt you were the
perfect person to shout out for that's
totally all month we were like gosh
we're six days into October should we
shout out and as the world's perfect
Matt beer he fits the personality of
every actor in this movie yeah your
breasts congratulations you get a Monday
video you should have wished for a
Thursday video that's one we're at our
best peak Thursday
you
hello there reject nation I'm John Rambo
and I'm rocky balboa I decided to
cosplay oh good this is John Rambo for
the song
you